[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
yeah it turns out there are a lot
there's a lot of iphones and no matter
what you think about the iphone the
first iphone this guy right here the uh
the original
it's pretty legendary it was unveiled at
mac world 2007 it was shown off in a
glass case it had that memorable steve
jobs moment on stage an ipod a phone a
breakthrough internet communicator these
aren't all three separate devices this
is one device it was pretty clear apple
had something pretty special on their
hands at that moment and you can mark
that day on the calendar as a pretty
obvious inflection point towards getting
to where smartphones are today now today
we're all the way up to iphone 13
lucky 13 and actually the 13 is a lineup
of phones it's a bunch of phones and
they all have world-class cameras lots
of proprietary silicon way more software
features and it's it's a tightly packed
collection of parts that would have been
basically impossible back in 2007 so
clearly a lot has happened since then so
today i've got every single iphone
that's ever been released 1 through 13
and i'm a review mall now some of them
i've seen before some of them i've never
even touched or held it's the first time
i've ever gotten them in the studio and
now they're working so i just wanted to
look back and see how far these phones
have come and it's it's actually pretty
incredible when you put them all next to
each other so
join me also stay tuned for the graphs
at the end we got some good graphs so
january 9th 2007 the first iphone so
here's a fun fact there's an article
from the guardian that shows that
apparently six out of ten americans knew
that an iphone was coming before it was
officially unveiled so this was an
incredibly hyped thing but it came out
and when it finally did it was
immediately pretty recognizable you've
got this two-tone design metal up top
plastic at the bottom for all the
antenna pass through a very recessed
headphone jack that actually prevented
lots of non-apple headphones from
working with it and this thing here
really set the tone for the rounded
corners the flat front and the general
ui of completely depending on a
multi-touch screen for everything
including a virtual keyboard which is
pretty bold at the time
now it had a bunch of things missing so
it had no app store on it when it
launched so basically you could use the
included apps and that's it and there
were some good ones you know safari is
here there's a youtube app google maps
was included there's a stock and weather
app but you couldn't get anything else
you also couldn't even set a wallpaper
every single non-jailbroken original
iphone was rocking the same wallpaper
absolutely nothing pitch black all these
numbers too are pretty hilarious but
let's just put them out there for
context three and a half inch display
two megapixel camera on the back it
launched with a four or eight gigabyte
storage version and the starting price
was 4.99 which was pretty expensive for
a phone it's one of the most
recognizable phones ever it's the only
one that had a sim card tray at the top
it's the only two-tone iphone they ever
made and fun fact this launched in well
it was announced in january but then it
didn't actually launch until five months
later in june basically and then
not till another eight months later did
they drop a 16 gig version but you know
looking back even though it obviously
had a lot objectively wrong with it and
a bunch of things missing about it there
was clearly a lot about the original
iphone
that stood out that was better than was
out on the market and that's why it had
such an impact
but there was a sequel and that sequel
was the iphone 3g
so this was called the 3g not the iphone
2 because it was the first one using a
3g network instead of edge and there
were some big changes first of all it
does feel a lot more like a refined
version of the original iphone actually
it's all black plastic now just smooth
like a pebble mainly because it's way
more tapered so it actually feels and
looks thinner but that actually does
lose you some space on the inside so the
battery in this phone is actually
smaller than the original iphone the
volume rocker and the iconic mute switch
that are already here kind of blend into
the side now though but software wise
this was another big step originally
there were no plans for an app store
like i said first one didn't have it
steve jobs said everyone should make web
apps for safari but they changed course
and reconsidered so this phone launched
with the app store which started with
500 apps in it and we all know how that
skyrocketed from there so this is iphone
os
2 on the iphone 3g
then we got the iphone 3gs the first
ever s update
s here we could safely assume is for
speed but also you could say it stands
for silver because really the only
difference on the outside is the text on
the back of the phone goes from gray to
reflective silver other than that this
one's the exact same design and
dimensions you could fit the same cases
as a 3g but the internals all got
upgraded so it's a faster chip made by
samsung that is literally twice as fast
toss in 256 megabytes of ram and a 3
megapixel camera and a slightly larger
battery you got yourself an s update but
looking back at it today i could also
argue the s stood first software because
it got some pretty big features again
iphone os 3 finally added cut copy and
paste finally
and believe it or not this was the first
year the iphone could actually record
videos in the camera app along with auto
focus and auto white balance i also
noticed the vibration motor got a lot
better on the 3gs it's a little smoother
and less rattly than the first two now
this is also the first iphone that had a
major gate attached to it so there was a
white version of the 3gs and it started
having weird discoloration issues turned
out to be because of heat
so apple ended up just recommending that
people not leave their phone in a car
for a long time in the sun or not use
their phone for an extended period of
time on a hot day
not ideal
kind of a classic apple response but it
turned out to be fine so iphone 4 i
think i can safely say was their best
new design and maybe their best design
ever it was hyped into oblivion from
that famous gizmodo leak before launch
but it eventually was revealed and we
still see shades of this iphone in
today's iphones so first of all it only
launched in one color black they had to
make a special white version later but
it's got the new square design that at
the time on stage was called the
thinnest smartphone on the planet at 9.4
millimeters and you know there were a
couple others that were a little thinner
but more importantly it's all flat sides
now on all the sides it's more grippable
it's more iconic it's got the circular
individual volume buttons it's all glass
and stainless steel
it's pretty sweet but then the feature
list this phone also got is crazy so
okay this is the first iphone with a
higher resolution display this is the
retina display which doubled the pixel
density and looked dramatically better
than any previous iphone then it was
also the first iphone to use an apple
branded chip so it was still made by
samsung but this now had a one gigahertz
apple a4 chip inside with half a
gigabyte of ram so now it supports
multitasking for the first time and apps
won't close when you jump between them
and this is the first iphone with a
selfie camera so you could have this
sweet new video calling service called
facetime plus they bumped the rear
camera up to 5 megapixels which let them
shoot 720p video and had enough fidelity
for 5x digital zoom and i also remember
this phone being really hot it was it
was talked about a lot even though it's
nowhere near the most popular iphone by
total sales it did break all the records
of all the previous iphones and it had
people waiting outside stores for it and
it sold 1.7 million in the first weekend
just just because it looked so different
it was so much better than the previous
phones that they'd made but also this
new design was the source of easily
apple's biggest gate yet
of course to have all these new antennas
on the outside in the stainless steel
band which is a really clever idea shout
out to johnny ive
but that also meant that when you grip
the phone like this which i guess you
could when phones used to be this small
it caused a it just dropped actually a
noticeable drop in signal strength
to the point where you would actually
drop a phone call if you're on the phone
and held it covering the antenna bands
this issue eventually grew so much that
apple issued a statement that it's not
that bad and the formula calculating the
number of signal bars isn't quite right
and we'll fix that with a software
update
but also don't hold your phone like that
but eventually they caved and made this
you may remember the legendary free
bumper case every iphone 4 buyer could
apply in an app to get a free bumper
what a classic
this is also the last iphone unveiled by
steve jobs himself so iphone 4s
this was again a small upgrade and again
mostly a speed
specs upgrade they clearly had a good
thing going with the iphone 4 so they
didn't change too much on the outside
other than again having a white version
and the antenna layout is improved of
course but this is definitely a
refinement there's a new 8 megapixel
camera shooting 1080p video and at this
point we're now on ios 7. tim cook
actually said in an interview though
around the time this phone came out that
the s in iphone 4s stood for
siri which came out with the phone and
was right around the same time that
google was coming out with their voice
assistant
early versions of siri were pretty rough
uh but of course it would start to get
better over time from that launch now
iphone 5 brought the biggest feature
literally that people were hoping for
that the 4s didn't bring that's a larger
display so this is the beginning of the
inflation of the iphone believe it or
not every single iphone up to this point
has had a three and a half inch display
this one is a four inch screen but it's
still a retina display still same pixel
density and still a pretty square design
but this time much more metal and it's
also much more durable because of that
and it felt more industrial especially
in the hand a little more heavy but this
is also the first iphone with lte and
the first one with a whole one gigabyte
of ram for even more multitasking on
this new massive display
but probably the most important change
here is the killing of the 30 pin
connector and the introduction of this
newer much smaller port
the lightning port
maybe the only bad thing that came from
this phone is when they replaced the
pre-loaded google maps app with a new
apple maps app which was just absolutely
terrible at launch but the bigger screen
and the beloved design combined and this
phone really took off in sales this sold
out 20 times faster than the 4 and the
4s and during the first 16 days of sales
it accounted for over 20
of all phones sold now android was
definitely heating up alongside it maybe
leave a thumbs up on this video if you
want to see an android version of this
look through history and make sure you
subscribe to see that if we get there
but you could say with the iphone 5
apple sort of caught lightning in a
bottle here
get it because
because the lightning
anyway the next year we got the iphone
5s
and the iphone 5c two very different
iphones so the 5s continued on the path
of the flagship iphone which had been
steadily increasing in price this one
now started at 6 49 at launch definitely
expensive at the time but very much
still a flagship and this actually is
the first iphone i ever owned and
reviewed this is actually the one i'm
holding right now it's still got the
squared off design but little
refinements like the chamfers and the
new gold color they included
but the most important new feature here
aside from even more speed is the touch
id fingerprint reader on the home button
now iphone 5c on the other hand is much
cheaper and a much more colorful option
to live alongside it in fact that's
probably what the c stood for cheap
colorful
but it's funny when you look back at the
pricing this was still in the days where
most iphones were linked to a two-year
contract so the iphone 5c was 99 bucks
with a contract while the 5s is 199 but
the idea is basically it's a repackaged
iphone 5 but now put in a plastic body
so some people love this design to me
it's it's a breath of fresh air it's
kind of like ipods but definitely wasn't
my favorite i do want to say though i
think both of these phones really showed
the pressure that apple was feeling from
the android world especially you know
apple likes to pretend no other company
exists they're just in their own little
vacuum comparing themselves to the
iphones they've already made it's the
best iphone ever of course it is uh but
i feel like this screen getting larger
was obviously there's a symptom of all
phone screens getting larger and larger
and offering that and more features
and then of course offering a cheaper
iphone god that's so neon but
you know there's much other cheaper
phones coming out and having the only
iphone be the expensive one wouldn't
bode well so they made both but then
came iphone 6 and 6 plus
er not my favorite designs of the iphone
ever and honestly they're probably not
apples either but on the other hand they
are some of the best selling most
popular smartphones ever made so they
probably don't mind that four million
plus on the first day 13 million in the
opening weekend jesus and 220 million
plus total iphone 6s and 6 pluses sold
jesus christ that's a lot of phones so
the squared off sides are gone now and
it's much thinner and the volume buttons
are even more elongated this is now the
first ever iphone with a camera bump but
really the biggest physical change with
these phones is
they are now relatively massive iphone 6
has a 4.7 inch display and this first
ever plus size phone here has a 5.5 inch
1080p display that apple calls retina hd
it's now finally gotten so tall that
they have to move the power button down
from the top over to the side so it
would still be reachable now i've
personally always liked the big phones
and anyone else playing in the android
world is aware that there's tons of
other big phones out there but this
from this i mean in one year that is a
huge step you might remember the word
phablet
pretty dumb word but you know there's
phones like the galaxy mega and these
are huge phones that are blurring the
line between a phone size
and a small tablet so
we're in this world now where we're
offering the biggest possible phone
and uh there would be consequences yeah
this phone started to have some
durability issues ben gate is probably
the most famous gate of all time there
is uh there's lou's video of course
spending the phone straight in half i
believe that is the most viewed tech
gadget video of all time correct me if
i'm wrong but really yeah this was
apple's first time making a phone this
big and you know in hindsight yeah
sheesh it's very thin and
it needed some structural reinforcement
so that is of course where iphone 6s and
6s plus come in so they fixed a lot of
the hardware issues reinforced 7000
series aluminum being one of them and of
course they were faster too another s
for speed how about doubling the ram to
2 gigabytes too not bad and at this
point we're on the apple a9 chip inside
which is still getting pretty huge
performance boost with each new iphone
they're on a pretty big ramp here but
the big new feature inside this phone
tell me if you remember this one
3d touch
a pressure sensitive layer underneath
the display that would let you
distinguish between a normal tap
and a deep forceful tap and it was
paired with this incredible new
vibration motor they call a taptic
engine so it had already been awesome in
the apple watch for a couple months and
in the macbooks track pad now it's in
the phone
and honestly i really liked 3d touch and
i miss it now spoiler alert it's
gone but it was really up to app
developers to decide what they wanted to
do with it a lot of it was just
previewing links inside a mini browser
and small shortcuts from home screen
icons
but this feature would not last very
long fun fact though this was another
year that the iphone had a smaller
battery than the previous year the new
reinforced aluminum and 3d touch took up
more internal room so he had a battery
shrink but also the camera bump in this
iphone
12 megapixel camera
2015. this is the first 12 megapixel
camera and every single iphone they've
ever made since then
has also had a 12 megapixel camera so
six months later we got a surprise
mid-cycle addition to the iphone lineup
the iphone se
so this is definitely a lot of people's
favorites it's actually the oldest
iphone out today that still supports the
newest version of ios ios 15 runs on the
og iphone se five-year-old phone and
this was really apple's move to bring
back this small phone and while the sc
officially stands for special edition we
can also easily call it the small
edition because this brought back the
smaller four-inch screen size back from
the iphone 5 series and even alongside
apple's other phones it's it's
impressively light and small
it was also cheaper and didn't have you
know flagship features like 3d touch it
was basically an iphone 5s with the new
chip and the new 12 megapixel camera
inside
but yeah this was the beginning of the
end of small phones right here every
tiny phone apple does from here on out
if you'll notice is some sort of a
special labeled edition
but apple still knows like people want
smaller phones and these tiny pocketable
flagship spec phones are very rare now
iphone 7 and seven plus were very
memorable and have left their mark on
the rest of the smartphone world for a
couple reasons so honestly even though
the design didn't change much i could
argue this is one of the most important
iphone updates ever first of all the
plus sized iphone had multiple cameras
for the first time ever so of course
there were some other phones that just
beat apple to the punch you know htc
made an evo 3d and htc had a 1m8 with a
depth sensor but this was just a
straight up second camera for telephoto
optical zoom and portrait mode which
would also arrive months after launch in
a software update by the way
but then second this was the first
iphone without any real physical buttons
so this home button for the first time
is just a solid glass surface with the
touch id fingerprint reader and the
taptic engine behind it so it doesn't
actually click it's the first force
touch home button
and as you know the home button has now
officially started to make its way out
but on top of all of this
this is the iphone that got rid of the
headphone jack mark it down september
2016
there's the infamous courage explanation
on stage the lightning earbuds bundled
in the box and of course you know other
smartphone manufacturers would
immediately start turning and making fun
of the iphone in any commercial in any
event they could get the chance but we
all know how that went from there
because as you know airpods were also
announced at that same event and they
would go on to become incredibly popular
wireless earbuds and everyone else wants
in on that action too which shifts the
whole landscape of what's expected now
from smartphone audio for better and for
worse also i just gotta say i i think
this single year that they ever did this
jet black was super sick even though it
caught all kinds of fingerprints and
scratches i loved it but also
this
felt like the first year that apple
started to think about two different
iphones one being a little more pro than
the other it wasn't called the pro but
the iphone 7 plus
was the one that had an extra camera and
it also had an extra gig of ram so
having portrait mode it just had a
little bit more
than the regular sized iphone so this is
the first time they're starting to like
branch that off now the next year in
2017 we got three iphones now it's
really branching off we got iphone 8 and
8 plus
and iphone 10. so iphone 8 and 8 plus
these are these are pretty minor
upgrades of course honestly pretty
boring same design as a seven same sizes
just a spec bump now and with true tone
and wireless charging and i will also
give them credit for being the first
smartphones to record 4k 60fps video so
there you go but they were immediately
upstaged and outshined minutes later
with the reveal of the iphone 10 that
big x everyone called the iphone x so
the true beginning of the future of the
iphone so this was a huge redesign that
was in the works for years
and honestly i personally loved it a lot
of things about it the home button is
gone
everything is gestures on the screen now
the bezels are also now mostly gone with
a new oled screen for the first time in
an iphone instead of an lcd that wrapped
right up to the corners and looked super
modern and the home button also being
gone means touch id is gone so instead
you have face id a whole facial
recognition suite with an ir blaster and
a dot projector in this notch up here at
the top but the thing about the iphone
10 that rippled through the smartphone
world more than anything else
the price tag 1
000
now you know over the years we had seen
phone prices slowly increasing you know
459 559 599 619 649 and actually the
iphone 8 and 8 plus at the time launched
at 6.99 and 7.99 but the base config 64
gig iphone 10
started
at a thousand bucks just jumped right up
to the top and i think the first
reaction was like
what you can do that you can charge a
thousand dollars for a phone and people
will actually buy it that was the thing
like it was a good phone
really nice oled screen much improved
over the previous generations but people
bought this phone a lot and i think that
kind of opened pandora's box for
everyone else going oh so we can we can
make a crazy high-end spec phone too we
can keep selling a cheaper one but we'll
make a lot more money if we do something
like this but another fun fact maybe the
biggest ding on iphone 10's legacy is it
is officially
the fastest discontinued iphone of all
time usually they keep around every
phone for like an extra year with a
discounted price this is one of the ones
that didn't stick around and it lasted
officially 10 months before being axed
when the 10s came out but that was the
new variation iphone 10s
iphone 10s max
and iphone 10r
okay so now that we've fully moved on to
this new form factor 10s is a refinement
and a spec bump in the same design same
size the difference is this time they're
also making an even bigger version with
a bigger screen and an even bigger price
tag called the max so they've gone from
plus now to max as the word they're
using and the bigger phone does have the
same specs as a smaller one but the max
has of course the biggest ever screen in
an iphone again jumping up to 6.46
inches really feels like a modern big
phone they couldn't go entirely super
high priced phones though so we also got
an iphone 10 r
which really was just them bringing the
iphone 8 into the new notch design now i
was not the biggest iphone 10r fan but
at the time you got to understand most
people don't need the highest end phone
and most people were not going to notice
the incredibly low resolution 720p lcd
versus an oled even though it was a 750
phone and they deserved better this was
the phone most people should get so this
is a colorful option that became the one
i recommended for most people even
though the 10s and 10s max were clearly
much better but they were just still so
damn expensive
now the next year 2019 the naming gets a
little simpler i guess
iphone 11
iphone 11 pro and iphone 11 pro max
maybe that's not simpler it's actually
more complicated but the iphone 11 is
the cheapest smallest iphone with an lcd
display what's crazy now though is this
baseline smallest iphone 11 has a larger
display than the previous plus sized
iphone 8 plus so the inflation has given
everything on the market bigger screens
but also now camera bumps are becoming a
design feature and the iphone has
settled into this relatively inoffensive
rounded off square in the corner and at
this point really the only knock on this
design is that all of the competition
has already moved on from the notch
already by this point they're all on
hole punches much smaller cutouts even
starting to do this crazy high-tech
stuff behind the screen but the iphone
is sticking with this notch and that'll
be a theme right up until the end of the
iphone here
then at the high end this was the first
year of apple doing a pro named phone so
now we've gone from plus to max
to pro and i honestly i think they're
just playing with the name to see what
they can get away with selling for more
money but here they have already killed
off 3d touch so the extra hardware is
gone and now it's just a long press that
we know today as haptic touch instead of
3d touch and this is the first iphone to
now have triple cameras on the back as
they've added their first ever ultra
wide shout out to lg for pioneering this
one rip so now we're starting to get to
what we recognize as the modern iphone
i'm also curious if you leave a comment
do you think they're going to move on
from the word pro to a different word
again
plus
max
pro
is there another word that could
continue to upsell better screens better
cameras better features better batteries
maybe but now we can't forget the crowd
favorite another mid-year refresh for
the second generation iphone se again se
is special edition but also this is the
smallest edition since this is now by
far the smallest iphone apple makes with
a 4.7 inch display it feels tiny
compared to the rest of the lineup and
really to the rest of the smartphone
world but that's the world we live in
now this is more or less an iphone 8
with a few tweaks and the new chip
inside and that alone is good enough to
make it one of the best options out
there especially in the camera and
performance department and i'm also
gonna say this is the best red they've
ever made
yeah it's the best ride they've ever
made also the 399 starting price really
puts things into perspective the fact
that this is the cheap phone now how
inflated the prices have become this had
to be their offering for competing in
the budget area where so many others are
kicking their butts this deserves a
chart it'll be a good chart but then
last year we got four new iphones all of
them slightly different but it's a whole
lineup now iphone 12 mini iphone 12
iphone 12 pro and iphone 12 pro max
and the square sides are back baby this
design now feels like if the iphone 10
and the iphone 4 got together and had a
baby a couple things here we did finally
get to 5g with this one
kinda if you saw the full review you
know what i mean but then the pro max
this time actually does have slightly
different impressively even better set
of cameras from even the pro and the
rest of the lineup including a larger
primary sensor with the new sensor shift
stabilization and this is also the first
ever year of a mini iphone which
hilariously has roughly the same screen
size as the plus sized iphone from just
three years ago from the iphone 8 plus
but this also continues the odd
tradition that apple seems to be keeping
going now of announcing a new camera
feature on stage but then not delivering
it in the phone on day one and figuring
it out with software update later so pro
raw a new camera codec for raw photos
from the iphone was announced on stage
didn't come out till two months later
but with the iphone 12 lineup we'll
probably be most famous for
is shipping in those new smaller boxes
that don't have charging bricks inside
it's a yet another move apple's made
that was made fun of a lot
and then literally a year later you
start to see other manufacturers samsung
xiaomi already doing it and i wouldn't
be surprised if this becomes the normal
in the smartphone world but
that's what we'll probably remember most
from the iphone 12 year but then last
but not least lucky iphone 13. and it's
the same lineup as last year from the
smallest cheapest 13 mini all the way up
to the largest most premium 13 pro max
another minor update on paper but as you
know it was to the three most important
areas of the phone the cameras all got
better across the board and i'm saying
these pros have the best camera system
in any smartphone on the market right
now so that's not bad then the battery
life got better across the board too
since the phones are now slightly
thicker and heavier than last year
because of the bigger batteries and the
displays got better particularly the
pros which now finally have a high
refresh rate promotion display that goes
up to 120 hertz and just to keep this
new tradition going prores video was
announced for the pro iphones
not on the phones yet as of right now
it's coming with a software update so
overall now counting all of the minis
and maxes and pros and pluses and ses
33 models of iphones have ever been made
i hope i'm counting that right
but that's over 14 years of the iphone
existing so there's been a lot of these
things and the fun fact now is there's
over a billion iphones active in use
right now but speaking of numbers
big graph guy here i really like seeing
these numbers visualized in some sort of
a beautiful graphic way so that's what
we're going to do here
i think this is the best way to
understand like how far these phones
have come or even just see some
interesting patterns so first one which
is kind of funny uh total storage that's
been in the iphone this is a graph of
the total storage size available in
every iphone of every year so we all saw
the first iphone launch with four or
eight gigabytes of storage which was a
pretty good number at the time but then
slowly year over year it's bumped up in
a pretty steady fashion until this year
the max storage size you can get on an
iphone is over a thousand gigabytes
that's pretty sick and it makes me
wonder where we'll all be you know
shooting prores video maybe to one
petabyte iphones in a couple years maybe
we'll see
performance has been also a pretty
steady curve upward shout out to moore's
law and while i wish i could do like a
geekbench score for every year or
something there is no geekbench score
for some early iphones but it's
interesting to see how the amount of ram
in these phones was stable for a bit at
one gig and then has been pretty
steadily ramping up since not as crazy
as some other phones out there of course
but that's cool to see but speaking of
stable here's a funny one megapixel
count in the cameras
we started with a 2 megapixel camera on
the original iphone then they got up to
8 which is kind of a sweet spot paused
for a bit and then they notched up to 12
megapixels with the iphone 6s and that's
been where every single iphone camera
has been since i kind of want to predict
like what the next number will be in
order to do 8k video they have to jump
up to 30 or 33
but we'll see where they go there's a
lot of companies whose megapixel charts
look absolutely crazy next to this one
screen size is another fun one though we
talked about the pressures of all the
rest of the smartphone world making
bigger and bigger phones the iphone was
a three and a half inch screen for a
while but then the dam broke and we got
bigger and bigger sizes
but they've also tried their best to
keep a somewhat small iphone in the mix
you got to respect them for that but
this also may be the last year we
actually see a really good mini iphone
so if you are still in the market for a
tiny one get one while you can
okay here's a fun one starting prices so
here are the starting prices for the
iphones released every year starting in
2007
all the way through 2021 off contract so
of course it's more common for people to
buy phones off contract now than they
did a decade ago but you can pretty
clearly see that ramp the 999 iphone
wasn't actually that monumental of a
jump from the previous phones it was
just such a mental hurdle though of a
number when you add a digit so also fun
fact the most expensive iphone you can
get right now
15.99 which is a lot more than the most
expensive iphone you could get at the
beginning which was 5.99 okay last but
not least just for fun we can visualize
sales the iphone clearly had a really
big surge from like 2011 to 2015
and the iphone 6 and 6 plus were a big
part of that they were the best selling
iphones of all time and i think it's
safe to say that is the best-selling
smartphone
of all time but now iphone cells are of
course plateauing they're closer to
saturated and that's why apple is
working on growing other categories like
services and accessories to the iphone
so that's how we got from here to here 1
to 13
what does the iphone 14 bring i don't
know
only the people working on it no but uh
i hope it has a port
that's all i'll say about that one
either way
that's been it thanks for watching
catch you next year apple
peace